many of you here our long-term visitors
or for a while some of you are coming
back and some of you are here just for
the first week so [ __ ] volume as our
stores already said this is this
workshop is part of program on logical
structures and computation which is a
very wide and diverse field of work and
as we organize this program we wanted to
focus it on interactions between two
shall we say silos within this field
logic in semantics on one hand and logic
algorithms on the other so we're looking
at ways of bringing these communities
together and someone we were planning
workshops we decided to focus the
workshops not on particular topics
within these idols but on themes that
come across them so the three workshops
are on the scenes of uncertainties
symmetry and compositionality so this is
the workshop on project symmetry
computation of this error as we go it's
the real title is the action of the
symmetrical best three on that set and
its really excited if you don't come
together and we have a named Roger
speakers and I hope you'll enjoy it very
much so without further ado I would like
to introduce our first speaker so I we
invited i should say three speakers to
give us longer one our talks serving a
particular area and it is my great
pleasure to introduce the person is we
go about our chick will be speaking
about orbit finite sets thank you fell
into that and thanks a lot for being i
let me letting me be in this wonderful
place scientifically on otherwise i
would like to talk about orbit
finiteness which is a concept that we've
been working on in warsaw but not just
us for a few years and the results will
be joined with some names that you can't
really read out and I
see that my this problem will continue
with the talk so in their other slides
the names are so small you can't even
see them that they're there so I just
mentioned them these are birthday clean
who is here and yeah now kramnik who is
also here and also eric Oh pinky suavo
meatless a tannish monitoring chick and
there's other people by involved as well
ah so the general idea is to to combine
logic and programming yeah what a fresh
idea and but in a specific way which you
see now I have tried to simplify the
concepts throughout the time and and
this would be if you've seen previous
versions of the stock I hope this is
simpler now the problem with simplifying
things is that they become trivial at
the end and you're ashamed of them and I
hope and I'm certainly makes it easier
for people other people to see that is
the same thing as that's been done
already so I'm opening myself up to this
kind of risk but willingly so I mean in
the name of progress so let me start the
idea is to of as I said combined logic
and programming in what sense so we're
going to fix some logical structure a
model functions and relations and we
will call that the atoms and then the
idea is that we're going to work with
things which are built out of the
crackers now this is an idea that's at
least a hundred years old it goes back
to to to to Abraham Frankel and models
of the permutation models of set theory
and it is in this spirit that this
development is going to happen but the
search of an infinite
it's a give the example to it has to be
infinite for this to be interesting I
think I mean these are the only examples
that we consider but it cannot be to
infinite for the exactly okay so it's
it's countable but more than that so for
example I give the examples and then
I'll discuss what are the assumptions
that you typically make and then they
will be there light in the top and
please ask questions all the time so the
canonical structure this is the one that
we started out with is natural numbers
movie-quality so this is because this
isomorphic structures lead to the same
theory this is just a countable set with
equality and that's that's that the
canonical servicing the simplest
possible infinite structure that you can
imagine and we stay down there okay
another one is going to be rational
numbers with order that's and that's
another one that's going to work out
fine these these structures are
homogeneous in the sense of moral theory
and what I might discuss in a moment and
that's going to be a sufficient
assumption for many things to work okay
so they're very tane for example their
first order theory collapses to to
quantify or three fragments that's
that's something that not me that's very
useful another structure that it some of
the things but most of them not but some
of them it will make sense would be just
a countable structure will defy with
first-order logic that's decidable so a
classical example of this is natural
numbers with addition this has a
decidable first order theory and some of
the some of the development will work
for that but this structure is a little
bit to infinite it's not homogeneous for
example that would mean that's many of
the things will not work okay and
another structure now say natural
numbers of multiplication just want to
get another example of a structure to
defy the decidable first order theory of
course there's more and so I will assume
that they're countable that that and
they have a decidable first order theory
and there will be other assumptions that
will appear one other assumption that
will appear
ah so now the idea is that we're going
to work with objects that are built out
of these atoms so we just fix that
destruction from now on when for example
if this is the one we fixed when I say
Adam and I mean a rational number and if
this is the one we fixed I mean some
natural numbers okay now the idea is
that we're going to build objects using
atoms in some kind of restricted way and
then compute on them and the idea is
that where we will be allowed to process
infinite objects so for example if we
will take this would be our atoms than
the set of all possible atoms although
technically infinite is going to be like
a finite object orbit finite in the name
from the in the sense from the name of
the little so just to give some syntax
the cumulative hierarchies just anything
you can build out from the atoms and set
brackets okay so technically speaking
it's indexed by ordinal numbers and you
know you can start out with an
individual atom or an empty set then you
can build anything that has combined
these things into sets so just anything
you can build with set brackets and and
and undie atoms and now we're going to
say which ones aren't ours ah now I'm
very weak and set theory but doesn't
that give you power set our service
because you know with SUV you continue
yeah and you continue forever so yeah
but we're going to live in a very tame
fragment of that not all of this is
going to be you're not going to be able
to process anything by algorithms
because here we have I don't know the
real numbers I know any subset of the
real numbers or something like that so
in particular you have all normal sets
we also have the apples in them and
they're going to play a role in defining
what it means to be finite okay and now
I will begin with the first notion of a
finite set it's going to be a special
example of something in the cumulative
hierarchy and i will call let's call
this a definable set so essentially a
definable set is
you think you can do like previous so
you know you do set brackets and so on
but you have to have a finite nesting
and when you build a new object out of
simpler objects that the set of simpler
objects has to be first order definable
so I make this explicit right now so
maybe just some examples if for example
your atoms are natural numbers then the
set of all atoms which is just a fancy
name for the set of natural numbers is
is a definable set now I'd like to
underline something I technically
speaking if you want to encode a natural
number that if you expand the definition
then it's it's technically speaking
defined as a set of something yeah like
five is the set of zero one two three
four so when we say this we don't parse
the atoms anymore okay they're like as
the name indicates their atoms so the
natural numbers which are the atoms are
a different thing than their you know
there are the new things that you can
construct which looks like the natural
numbers another example of a definable
set is the set of all pairs of distinct
apples okay another example so as you
can see well technically speaking I
should define what it means to pair but
use some you know set theoretic coding
of the cutoff scopare function or
whatever so you can use pairs and here's
a more fans example which I like a lot
and for some reasons that we will talk
about at the end of the talk so this is
the set of all sets of size free of sets
of size 2 of atoms and so as you can see
it nests so like a set of sets of sets
okay that's you're allowed to do that
and then the constraints are allowed to
be using this so we can only say what
sequel was not equal to the only type of
constraints in this particular atom
structure would like to do this
particular set will be nice because it
will be the simplest input alphabet for
Turing machines so the tuning machines
over this input alphabet do not
determine eyes that's why I put it
it so that it has special role and it's
it's DC the number six so you can't make
it go down to 50 k definable sets can i
use parameters yeah so I will define
define will set in a moment's right
right right so they could have a free
variable yep for example any individual
atom like five is a definable set of set
is a kind of bad name because not a set
but yeah it's assignable thing okay and
so for the rational numbers you're
allowed to write constraint which shop
about the work yes so for example you
could take the set of this is supposed
to be the set of all intervals so here
inside the brackets you have something
which has a parameter a and B and given
parameters a and B you define the
interval from A to B and then you can
bind that parameter and have something
without parameters okay so the general
definition just to give the syntax is
you use something I call it an set
builder expression so you can start off
with a variable this is the parameter
and the idea is that then you
instantiate it some Adam and then if you
have you can have a floor you can have a
finite unit of expressions of the forms
that you take a simpler expression which
is already definable this represents a
set with a lot of parameters some of
them will remain to be free and some of
them will be bound so you say that for
all Possible's of the bound variables
said that some constraint hold and the
constraint has to be first order
definable so the parameters are just the
atoms so you're allowed to talk about
relationships between the atoms which
your atoms allow so for example if your
atoms are rational numbers you this can
be a first-order formula using order if
your atoms have this equality this can
only use equality and so on it's pretty
Pressburger arithmetic then you can do
other things and I use the word
definable said you take something like
this it has a certain number of free
variables and then you instantiate them
to 22 atoms that's it it becomes the
parameters English ok so that's
definable sets all of these things are
definable sets but you can also do it
for I don't know Pressburger arithmetic
for example if you take this structure
then you could for example
I all pairs the binary relation of on
pairs of natural numbers which is the
you know transition function of them to
counter Minsky machine it's in this
truck tricker community structures have
equality yep I don't think that plays
much of a role but if if there's nothing
to be gained by disallowing equality so
and therefore yes so you can write
definable set and as this example shows
even if your if your atoms are chosen to
be Pressburger arithmetic then you can
define quite dangerous set and for
example you can't take the transitive
closure so you know won't be able to
compute too much okay however if they
will be like this you will be able to
compute a lot and that's the point of my
talk so uh but so far i only make the
assumption that they have a decidable
first order theory so you know if you
have such a constraint here it's you
know you can decide which will be useful
to do anything for it so so far I just
assume that the atoms have decided first
or theories and let's consider a program
okay just for the sake of an example is
suppose that the atoms are rational
numbers and this is a program like in
that the language settle some of you
have seen this you manipulate sets and
you can loop over element subsets your
variable store sets but now your
variable store definable sets okay and
you can loop over definable set so this
particular program it's going to check
if this is a reef total order no I think
it's going to check you yeah we will see
what a text okay it's a stupid program
just an example so it you start off with
a set this is supposed to be the set of
pairs in the order which which are good
I'll explain that and then you
initialize a variable Y to the set of
all atoms this is an example of a
definable set so you can load the
definable set into a variable that's
what
so in general in variables you store
definable setting you manipulate okay
and now you can do a for loop across
something that's in a variable so that's
an infinite set but you can still do the
for loop I will explain what the
semantics are in moment okay so now I
loop over all rational numbers or all
rational numbers so here I have all
pairs of national rational numbers and
then I check if for this pair is the
case that is either smaller bigger or
equal so it's you disallow incomparable
pairs and if it's true i add this to my
set okay now in the end I say if I I
have all possible at impairs than I
print this okay good and the end I will
because that order on rational numbers
does not allow incomparable pairs now
the point is that you can execute set
programs so you can write a program like
this and as long as your structure has
decided a first order theory you can
execute it and a result will come out I
will explain the semantics in a moment
to say when when does it terminate okay
but it often terminates in particular
this example will terminate and just to
be concrete there is an implementation
looping over internet sets there's two
and the second one will be presented by
Bartok later in this workshop but the
one that I'm talking about now was it
similar although the semantics are a bit
different than the ones that i will
present its developed by helicopters can
assume intolerant chicken it's a see
library and what you can do is you can
write C programs let's have such a sea
program and let's have a look at it
maybe in test
so what's going on here let's let's have
a look maybe that the font is too small
you can see there's this for loop here
okay now there's a lot of letters here
but this for loop is the exact same kind
of for loop that I have my example thank
you simple yes so but I'm not sure to
allow infinite sets so that's that's the
point of of this language so if it says
you can do any definable set if it so
happens that you're Adam structure that
you have fixed has arithmetic for
example Pressburger arithmetic has a
little bit of arithmetic then it will
have that kind of arithmetic but if it
doesn't then you want and you really
don't want it to have a rithmatic
because other sorry i guess but i still
think that you would not be allowed to
to I mean I'm I want to be categorical
about this but I believe you were not
allowed to store infinite sets in your
variables which is the key thing here so
the key thing of this talk is that if
you slightly expand the notion of a
finite set to cover definable sets then
you can still work with them that that's
that's my point that the fact that we
you do it using a language similar to
settle is of a secondary concern so for
example bar click we'll talk about a
functional programming language which
does the same kind of idea to execute in
parallel things which are infinite power
sorry whose powers we have a low battery
warning
story and said wait a minute and I think
anybody I lost my
I would we didn't get very far so is it
I don't I'm not sure it's a zoomed-in
properly okay so so just to us since we
proud to profit double terms we fix a
structure like this which may or may not
have arithmetic and then we can have a
program where the variables store
definable sets and you know execute on
okay come to this is so important
suppose you take real numbers with
knitting and you get work your finite
objects are descriptions that that's
true so if you would take for example
the attacks keys arithmetic almost
everything will work yeah I assume
countability for its not doesn't play
much of a role in the beginning and then
at some point would play a little bit of
a road but but tarsk arithmetic
essentially is covered by the theory and
it's essentially covered as a
non-example so as it spread press will
get arithmetic so that's what we do have
definable set and now we can run
programs on them so for example if you
took a program which would compute graph
readability and your input so a
transitive closure of a relation you can
easily imagine a program which does that
and you ran it on this you wouldn't
count the problems okay so i will
discuss that in a moment so this is a
programming language and now i try to
explain what is the semantics of the for
loop the general idea is that if your ad
on the rational numbers you don't really
need to try this for every rational
number you can just try it for one like
three and because free looks the same
like any other rational number yeah if
you only talk about the order now once
you have fixed a to be like your one
example say free then you don't need to
really look at all other bees there's
just like you take 5 and minus 1
and three so that's what you have to do
that's that's the whole theory okay ah
and guess what is the question is might
it matter what where did you take the
matter so this I will explain giving the
semantics and the answers note that says
very important that the semantics is
defined in such a way that it's it
doesn't matter what the order is so you
could imagine from that an order order
invariant semantics that you that the
formal semantics is that you just
execute it but it has the property that
no matter what the order is it does that
that's not what i'm going to do you it
will have you will not use order and
barons well let's just do like you on
that was exactly from the destination so
what do we do so suppose we have want to
execute this for loop for every element
of the set X do this instruction ok now
I just didn't do an operational
semantics or program state it just
assigns to each variable you know some
definable thing that's in it definable
set can be an individual atom ok so
maybe not a well-chosen thing now what
is the semantics of this so I have a
program state and i want to say what is
the program state after executing this
which might be undefined because of the
loop might not terminate so what I do is
this you know this set can have maybe
one an element or another element and
you know it has a lot of elements may be
countably infinite lee many which is
what I you typically assume but it could
even have uncountably many that doesn't
dismantle it will be well defined ok now
what you do is well so far it's obvious
thing to do for every element of the set
you execute the body of the for loop and
you get a new program state which
depends on the choice of your element ok
so I executed here I get you know some
value I executed here I get some other
value and so on so I have a lot of
program states but now I mean it's split
into parallel execution but I wanted to
come back to a single execution so I
want to aggregate all of these programs
States into a single one now first of
all it might be the case that here you
need five time steps to finish here you
might need eight time steps to finish
here down 26 and so on so it might be
the case
that depending on your element you need
unbounded times to terminate in that
case the semantic says that the for loop
does not terminate which is I guess what
you would expect so the running times
let's call these threads the running
time though these parallel threads are
unbounded then the whole for loop is not
terminate otherwise the running times i
should say what the running time is but
it's an intuitive definition of running
away except precisely never exactly so
so if you're running times are all
unbounded then that doesn't terminate
but if they're all bounded by eight for
example then first of all i define the
running time of the whole for loop to be
nine so that explains what running time
is and just either you read it in number
that has um you know billion bits that
takes constant time how long it is and
you havin this constant under I'm sorry
didn't get that it's an operation like
edition is kinds of time yeah and this
yeah so because here we're just
interesting about finite time then yeah
but it's true that I treated like in an
abstract way so so if it was for example
Pressburger arithmetic and I would the
loop would go for every natural number
in the set of all natural numbers
incremented then that's true that this
will take this will be okay and yeah if
so that ignores the fact that the longer
not read natural numbers require more
bits be incrementally Tomic operation it
takes if that is that that was that you
okay so now i need to aggregate but
first of all this is what it means to
terminate and now how do you get the
program state so you need some kind of
aggregation to put all these programs
state into one and let's use the
following one which is this aggregated
program state in variable Y what does it
store well first of all it might have
been the case that all of these Fred's
didn't do anything to program to the
river white was just nothing happened to
you so if if all of the pro all of the
threads have the same value in Y then
just use that value ok so for example if
this was a no op
then the new program state would do no
okay otherwise all of these frettin some
of these threads have different value
and then I need to aggregate them into
one value but the thing is we're working
with sets so there's a natural
aggregation function which set Union and
this thing what we use okay so otherwise
you put here the set union of all things
that you found there okay so that's what
you use and that's the end of the
semantics ok and as you can see it that
it is automatically ordered back because
set union is is this is important
variant thing ok so that's it and the
programming language this is the for
loop but you could have you know while
while in the usual sense conditionals
and other programming constructs that
that's in depth that's defined in it in
the natural way ok so that's your
programming language and the theorem
says that if you have such a program and
you have a representation of the program
state at the beginning for each variable
a definable set and if according to the
semantics it terminates then you can
actually just run it on this you know
C++ program and and it will tell you
what's at the end ok so that's the
programming language ah this completes
the first part of my talk which is about
what a definable set it confused about
your situation said union is the set of
all elements as Sigma 1 Sigma 2 for you
say yes is this it is the set of all
elements which belong to variable Y for
some thread so for example if your if
one of the thread ends up with an atom
in it then an atom has no elements so it
would be lost in this opinion just
can you get definable sets click United
th exponential yes I'm not so up I'm not
sure I exactly understand the question
but I try to give some some answer which
would be that the role countable those
which finally oh I see I guess that if
you choose your so for example one would
have to measure the size of but but
essentially speaking yes so you can have
a ten nested for loops in the in the
atoms which are equality so typically if
ur and you have you cannot have program
which has a really finite set with say n
elements now you would expect that if
you have a series of ten nested for
loops then at the end you could make
your set to have size n to the power of
10 but this is not what's going to
happen I'm not exactly sure about the
example I gave is correct but I think
it's something this then at the end of
10 nested for loops your size could have
more or less 2 to the power and of 10 so
nesting for loops is not a polynomial
construction in something like this car
America can be defined prime sharp it ya
know in order you can in its column
arithmetic you can write the set of
prime numbers is a definable set so
first of all you can define it using a
one-line program which says X becomes
all primes because in the programming
language you're allowed to load the
definable set which is hard-coded into
your program that's that's legal but if
you were even if you're not allowed to
do that that's actually syntactic sugar
because you can do a for program which
would our
like this which would start off with
just a set of scholar marreth metric and
then execute in finite time and have
prime numbers in one of the variables
just by formalizing the first order
definition of a prime number in Scala
method which is like two quantifiers or
something so that the for loops
correspond to quantifiers is what they
do yes so every symbol in your signature
takes constant time to evaluate or
compute yes when I to you when I ya know
a number so just go back your program
what would happen if you why would it
take bound the time say I'm so here you
see that you rely on the path the depth
the definition of this test takes
constant time yeah but when you are
redefine X this also takes constant time
so it is each individual operation
Thanks constantly but something about
termination he relies on this thing
being positive they Exeter and
positively on the right any program
which has the phone if your atoms are
first-order definable any program of the
form two nested for loops a conditional
and an assignment is going to terminate
because this has constantly has running
time one this together has running time
to this has a running time free and the
whole thing has running down for every
program of this form will terminate if
however in the body here you would have
a while loop then depending on your
choices of a B you could imagine that
the while loop would take maybe five or
eight steps or 26 and then you would run
you would start to talk about the
determinate or not however if you
disallow for a while loops and you can
only use for and if and assignments and
sequential you know composition of
instructions and every program is going
to terminate period this just a running
time depends
on the number of old bridge yes and yes
and nope so it is also well defined for
a structures where so the number of
orbit is sort of an upper bound on the
road a no yeah but it could be that
there's anything too many orbit and yet
it it runs in finite time so because
this programming language also covers
structures where the notion of orbit is
not such a reasonable notion and we'll
the orbiter which is exactly this plane
was bothered me so semantically will
work with definitions now if you have
finite sets which I exponential size in
definition in the programming language
stores them then it becomes infeasible
to run the program
that is so that that's true so I if the
focus here is not really on feasibility
as in for example polynomial time this
programming language no it's it's just
you're happy if it terminates in finite
time this is the this is the view here
so we're not worried about that although
we should be but we have to so you got
to start somewhere okay so this is just
about termination in finite time which
is already nice i mean if you can tell
you know loop over an infinite stretch
and finite time that's already a nice
thing we just 22 22 we have no idea we
have very little idea about what it
means to be quickly computable this is
something that we have not developed
properly ok Eric commenter time that
that sounds fascinating and the thing we
talked about the times you have some
ideas like you were talking about the
less than greater than or equal is you
know they're only been different cases
see you again so there is some notion
that could be filled yes so you could
you could do than that so and if you if
you look at this theorem which says
actually what it will say is that you
can compute it in time and the time is a
function of evaluating first order
formulas and yeah so that you get from
the theorem because it's just just how
you evaluate and then yeah that gives
you something you have just four loops
confident to say back everything yes you
can so if you if you have a wild free
program then what it will do is it if it
inputs a definable set then it will
produce just a new definable said what
everything producing you define was said
but if you have no wires then you can
just write out the new definable set in
terms of the old one just rewrite it
bye-bye substitute to death yes well
even if the wires yet yes so there is a
connection with fixed point logics
although I would prefer i prefer this
because i think it's more intuitive but
yeah yeah okay
just to be sure about this Emily what
happens if you have X equal just a be
this that's so this will give the exact
same result so I wrote it like this so
that it will be intuitive but it it's
it's an equivalent program would be if
you have this no sorry there my hand
doesn't cover it i just put my finger
and projector because every thread will
be executed in a situation where x is
empty so actually adding it is the same
thing as setting it to it and but the
semantic sages say set Union so maybe
this was this is more intuitive at the
first glance but it may be lead you down
the wrong road because you think there's
some atomic operation like add something
no it's just set it that means that if
you want to do the other way round up
from Adam square and remove them you
simply can't do it with this semantics
you can because you can subtract things
yeah but you take the union of
everything you're suspected at almira so
no no youyou you compute the compliment
but that that is to be abided by not by
this semantics is the programmer who
does that yeah so you could have
equivalently modified the programming
language so that you get two different
for loops that Union for loop and
intersection for loop if that would be
syntactic sugar you could do that and
actually so there's a theorem I mean
it's nice to have a discussion so I'll
ignore my slide sorter what you can
prove like in slide 15 is is that this
programming language is complete in the
sense that it can compute everything
that you could complete in the natural
sense and what does that mean it means
to justify why this particular language
enough so many some other language you
could imagine now here let's use the
assumption of accountability so suppose
that the atoms have are countable there
they have an effective enumeration and
the first ordered theory is is decidable
even with free variables
that means that you can write down
definable set in a finite space because
you just write the set-builder
expression of the natural numbers which
represent the Verde the parameters so
you can encode a definable sets of
numbers and therefore you could ask you
could have a different notion of a
computable function which says I input a
definable set written down as a number
then I use a normal touring machine
which transforms numbers and then I get
a new number and then I convert it back
to a definable set that would be an
alternative definition of as a
computable function on definable sets
now what you can show is that being
computable by a program like this and
being computable in that alternative
definition is the same notion and that
means that if you added construction to
your programming language like intersect
loops or other stuff that would not give
you anything new okay so this is this is
this is like a robust notion of
computability sorry so sorry give you
joy to see all right it's great but you
get that using the surname I guess I
should I don't know Church touring with
atoms or something so so so the church
touring with Adams says well maybe it'll
get to slide 15 will circuit which is
unlikely I guess how much time do I have
another
about 20 minutes 20 minutes what I
wanted to do is talk about symmetry okay
so so far the programming language is is
in the just assume that you have a
first-order side with first order theory
and so far we have not seen so much the
difference between natural numbers of
equality which is a tame structure and
pressburger arithmetic each other side
of our theory but is not very tame
structure the problem though I mean I
indicated that you want the able to do
transitive closure but i'll try to
describe that in more detail right now
so remember at the beginning we said
that you can have set which are built
out of atoms and then here we define
definable set which are sets built out
of atoms in the first order definable
first order define work this was a very
synthetic notion it said definable set
is anything that can be described using
this syntax ok now what I will do is I
will present orbit finite sets which is
a semantic notion okay which says an
orbit finite set is anything which
satisfies the following semantic
property ok so that's the other view on
definable sets and the beautiful thing
is going to be that it's the same nose
ok and that will allow you to use
syntactic constructions when they're
convenient and semantic construction
when they're ok and in the semantic
notion as you can see from the name
orbit is orbit as and group action so
the notion of symmetry will play a role
ok so now let's talk about orbit
finiteness orbits finiteness ok so i
will use the word of by automorphism in
what an autumn our business so it's a
it's a permutation of the structure
which preserves all the relations and
functions ok the idea is that asset is
orbit finite if it is finite up to
bottom morphisms of the atoms that's the
sort of end of the definition ok i will
say a lot of words but that's it ok so
if you take the group if you take the
group action of the automorphism jean on
the set built out of atoms then it will
have finitely many orbits now this has
to be made more precise which I'll try
to right now okay just to indicate some
of the
examples because this will be important
so autumn orphans of natural numbers of
equality are just all permutations okay
autumn morphisms of the ordered
rationals are monotone permutations and
just okay and for example if you take
these two structures natural number of
order or natural numbers addition is no
tomorrow okay because okay so these will
be bad and these would be good okay as
we will see in a moment because if there
are no automorphisms then being finite
up to automorphism is a meaningless
concept well it's a meaning full concept
but it's called being finite yes so you
want it to be meaningful and therefore
you want to have some autumn or so and
actually want to have a lot of optimism
this is so that it's it's quite easy to
be finite up to autumn ours okay so
let's let's define what it means to be
orbit finite as I said it means you have
finitely many orbits up to automorphism
so let's define a one orbit set is a set
of the form you take something built out
of atoms so something in the community
priority okay and now you if you have
something built out of atoms and you
have an autumn office of the atoms and
you can just apply to it you know
recursively until you reach anatomy
rename it Adam and the definition says
that you take the orbit of it but now
look I'm not using all automorphisms but
I also allow a parameter here so this is
this a little bit of the subtlety of the
notion so if I so in order to define a
one orbit set you need to give two
things which is you need to give
something called the support which is
just atoms and you need to give the
center of the orbit which is you know
whats around which you're going to go so
I a one orbit set with Center X and
support this is you start in the center
and you apply to it any other morphism
which however it does not do anything to
these important atoms as a one orbit set
and actually
I'd like to say that the note number one
orbit said does not really make sense
but i'll just use it here for a brief
moment so let's have an example so
suppose that our our atoms are this and
we have support one and two so i will
only allow adam automorphism which fix
one and two okay and suppose that my
Center is the triple zero one two so
where can I go from that well I can
apply any autumn morphism which fixes
one and two so these the second and
third coordinates will remain unchanged
but the first one can go anywhere
essentially except for one and two ok so
the orbit with around that well for
example contains 712 because there is an
auto mode or automorphism with maps 0 1
to 2 7 12 and does not do anything we
wanted to ok and here instead of seven
you could have any other number which is
not one or two ok so that's the orbit so
the orbit this one orbit set consists of
all triples of atoms here which have one
and two on the second coordinate and
something which is not one nor two on
the first coordinate that's an example
of a one orbit set and as you can see
it's because I wanted to have parameters
into said and it sends a needle demanded
Nene last about that's why I have one
and you need to have parameters because
for example you have even if your entire
program does not refer to any happens by
netting once you execute a for loop you
will introduce some stuff and in the
middle you will have to manipulate
things with parameters so that they're
necessary okay so that's a one orbit set
and an orbit finite set is a finite
union of such things okay so that's the
definition of an orbit finite set now if
I use the name one orbit set that sort
of suggests that you can count the size
of a setting you know how many orbits
doesn't have but that's not really
legitimate because if you you could it
depends on the support because if you
make the support bigger the orbit goes
smaller because it's more difficult to
be an autumn or fees which preserves
more things and it's not so clear while
it needs to count where you could
imagine some ad hoc Nelson
I don't think they have a well-behaved
theory so let's talk about this but this
is the keynote okay orbit finite sets
and as I said if you extend the support
will make that orbit go smaller because
it's more difficult to be an automotive
that's this is something so suppose for
example that we added five to the
support and we kept the same center then
we would have to use auto morphisms
which preserve one two and five so for
example I will not be able to reach 5 1
and 2 so that this particular orbit will
break into two pieces one of which is a
singlet but in general it will break
apart into many orbits and you could
imagine that if you extend the support
that orbit might break into infinitely
many pieces and now I introduce the key
thing which is called a legal morphism
which is going to be a constraint on the
atom structure which will ensure that
this will not happen and therefore the
notion of finiteness will be well
behaved so now I define a nautical
morphic structure and so a logical
structures called a lyga morphic if
every power not just the structure
itself but pairs triples and so on has
finding too many minutes so for example
the natural number is equality because
if you look at the end power of it up to
automorphism to to preserve the same if
they have the same equality type so it's
fine income inequality type and that's
okay actually if you take a homogeneous
structure in the sense of model theory
and it happens to be over a relational
vocabulary which is the case for this
then it's going to be all ego morphic
it's not so difficult to prove okay and
a corollary is that this structure is a
illegal morphic this structure is
illegal morphic and a nice example is
the random graph where you taken an
infinite countably infinite set and for
each ad direct directed that for example
you flip a coin and then with
probability 1 you get the same graph up
to isomorphism which is called a random
graph and it is homogeneous and
therefore Oregon vortex oh that's
examples of illegal morphic structure
however Pressburg arithmetic which is
are the non example in
going to be a legal morphic because it
has no automorphisms and its infinite so
it cannot be finite up to optimus
sometimes you need to go to some higher
power in order to have a violation of a
little more efficient so for example if
you take the integers with order now
here the automorphism are just plus 1 or
plus 5 and up to that if there's only
one integer because from three to eight
you can go by the automorphism at five
however if you go two pairs of integers
then has infinitely many things that
totem or if it's because they this
difference between two integers is
invariant okay so that's all good more
it's a very important motion for this
theory ah this I think dates at least
from the 50s they're really not jeske
theorem for example doxa belton it's
important for our theme okay now a fact
is that if you take your atoms to be a
little more thick then this does not
happen which means that if I have a one
orbit set and I extend the support
somehow it will break apart into smaller
orbit but still fine I team in and
therefore having finitely many orbits is
a robust concept you don't have to say
under which support okay and i would say
that you're only allowed to talk about
orbit finiteness if you're oligo morphic
because otherwise you will need to
specify the supports and it's a it's a
bad notion okay so this is the severe
you're only allowed to use automorphic
structures so we're not going to be
using we're not going to be using
facebook girl so that's the notion of
orbit finite okay and so we have two
constraints what two kinds of sets that
can do to that this is just syntactic
notion and this says anything you can
build to it from atoms which has a
semantic property that up to symmetry
its finite so we have two notions let's
extend this one to something called
Harry terribly orbit finite which means
that you as a set our orbit finite but
the sets you contain are also orbit
finite
and so on and so on ok that's a hair
thoroughly orbit finite set now what you
can prove is so you have an eternity
orbit finite certainly have this defined
with semantic notion syntactic notion
and what you can prove yes ok let me go
back will you go much for a moment so I
left all categories thin slice illegal
market is equivalent to say cleaver
fastest tender that's a real nerd esky
theorem yes so only the morph is a very
good notion no no this is a name that
that's just not mine I didn't change it
so there are two definitions yes one is
defined in terms of orbits and the other
is in terms of theories and they're real
modeski theorem says that they coincide
now why do I use one of the two names
the less common one well the reason is
that the other day automorphic side of
the renal jeske theorem is what really
works here most of the time so that's
why I use it but i don't know maybe
that's the sign up you made types of
permutation group actually and have
people talk about oracle malted yeah i
thought i looked it up on the internet
and that is the name I was supposed to
use but I I mean I have no problem with
changing it but what I want to say is
that I want to uh the group side as
opposed to the the theory side because
that's what makes a lot of this work
although actually in the translation
from here to here you use the theory
side because a corollary I mean well the
proof of their energy theorem is that if
you are an orbit finite set of tuples of
atoms say five to put the bathrooms and
you're necessarily definable first order
logic which is what makes this whole
thing work so there's a that's sort of
like the main engine behind this okay so
now we have two things and they're the
same so if the atoms are or they go
morphic then this is equal to this now
so it's nice to have to characterization
so one is very nice because you know if
you're defining with the syntactic
notion so you can write them down
you can have these programs programming
language which works for it the other
one is nice because because what I don't
know so so far there must be an
advantage of this but it's it's I don't
know because it fits student with the
name of the workshop maybe symmetry ah
now what I like to do in the last five
minutes is to explain what is good for
so let's do the following thing let's
consider graph each ability so this
program it in puts us at vertex set and
headset and a set of source vertices
maybe not more than one and it computes
everything that's reachable from s ok so
it's obvious algorithm it's a it's a
loop so you know you if you have an edge
and it intersects your source set then
you add it to your source you know just
add the in the first iteration you will
add things reachable in one step in the
second iteration you had things Richmond
this in two steps and so on and to
compute each step you do the for loop
ranging over an entire episode okay
that's the problem now as I said this
program can be executed in an arbitrary
structure with first orders defining the
side with first order theory for example
in press burger if mythical what will
happen there well that would be a little
bit of a problem so first of all the
body of the for loop as I said it's a
wild free program so it is always
guaranteed to run in finite time okay
let's call it running time free but
actually if you implement it then in
that you have to factor in it's three
times the cost of the deciding the first
order theory okay however there is no
guarantee that the repeat loop the
number of phases the number of steps you
need to consider that that will be
finite that is not guaranteed and it's
you can come out eating with example so
for example if you're at the pressboard
arithmetic and for example your vertex
set is all pairs of numbers and for
example your edge set is increment the
first coordinate but leave the second
coordinate unchanged then and for
example your source says that I
no used to have a picture so this is
your original this is the set of
vertices reachable zero steps then you
take one step you go up by one now based
on a representation of this diagonal you
can compute a representation of this
this new diagonal in finite time but
then this will not terminate of course
because go for it so that's not going to
terminate however and this is the main
point of this talk is that if you assume
that your atoms are not press burger it
may be but they're only good more thick
then this program is guaranteed to
terminate in finite time why is that
well that's a seer this terminate
program terminates in tiny time when the
atoms are all the course because what
you do is just steps I mean I get as
some of you see it straight away so what
you do is this is your input and you
choose atoms let me maybe write it here
more in zoom in you choose atoms such
that you know your vertices your edges
and sources you have three things on
your input V E and s and every
quantifies over these three things now
not over all possible input but once
your input is fixed you choose atoms
which support everything in it that
means that your vertices are a finite
union of orbit with this support your
edges are a finite union of orbit of
this support and your source things are
a finite union of things with the
support and order go morphism guarantees
you can do that because if its orbit
finite and you just add extend support
so that you have the same support for
every orbit maybe I skip over this is
just a justification of why I can do
this but I won't do that right now so we
choose atoms so that the vertices edges
and sources each one is partitioned into
orbits with exactly the support okay now
so the picture is this these are
vertices and they break apart into
orbits with this support okay finitely
many now I have my source vertices which
are just some of these orbits I have
assumed that my atoms were chosen so
that they support all for the source
vertices so the source vertices they
break apart
25 finite number of orbits but these are
the same orbits is using vertices that's
why I could just identify some of the
orbit and now the key observation is
that every iteration of the repeat loop
that that's not something every
iteration of the repeat loop will just
either add an entire orbit or nothing
okay why is that will suppose let's
consider the first iteration of the
repeat loop and suppose that I added
this vertex that means it's connected
here by a net now suppose I take
something else in the same orbit which
means that there is an automorphism pi
which maps this to that and fixes the
support but that means that this is also
the case because this is an orbit with
respect to the same support and
therefore there's an edge because the
set of edges is also invariant under
such things okay so that means I one
thing I had all other things and
therefore if I do my program it will
just continue adding orbits in this case
the graph is connected so it would
saturate but otherwise it would just
stop at some finite amount of time so
that's the benefit of that using
symmetry a number of things will work in
finite time so that the programs are
well behaved and I want it but I won't
have time to do that to discuss two
examples of this theory so I won't go
there but just say what they would say
one thing is if this is our was our
original motivation you'd consider outer
matter so you call it an automaton orbit
finite if every component of it is
definable or equivalently hair tutorial
yorba tonight now what you will get is
that non emptiness is decidable for an
automaton because it's a reach ability
problem and I just show you the album
for accessibility and you can see it
crucially relies on the fact that it's
all been worth it and the other example
was Turing machines so you define a
Turing machine to be definable if
everything in it is definable ok and now
it's so it turns out that this leads to
a quite an interesting theory for
example what is the computational
Universal model maybe I'll just go go to
the last slide on
as I've finished so let's forget this so
you consider a language our function
from words 22 22 22 years now to be
computable this is the wrong definition
you shouldn't use you shouldn't use
tuning machines but if you do then this
is what happens the universal model is
going to be alternating to it machines
not deterministic ones and not even I
think not even non deterministic once
okay so you can prove that this is the
one and alternation is because you use
first order theory so there's two kinds
of quantifiers okay however if your
atoms are a homo demand homogeneous
structure which covers many examples and
maybe almost all of them this is one
more line then non-deterministic is
enough however deterministic is never
enough so there's a theorem that we
prove together with perfectly
instrumental in chicken so that's outta
that for example over this fancy
alphabet triples of pairs unordered then
you can do it you can read it or not
it's some language over this alphabet
then you can do it by a non non
deterministic machine even in polynomial
time whatever that means but you cannot
do it by any deterministic one returns
in finite time and the reason for that
is the Thai furor in Mad Men
construction which you might recognize
because there's three and two which
appear
okay so that's all I have to say thank
you any more questions necessary small
point in here problems there equality is
definable there are some examples of
other homogenous structures in
connection to equality so one example is
is this that this is something that we
did together with shimanto in chicken
looks a goof on we were interested in
XML and we want it so in the rational
numbers sort of like it's a limit of all
finite orders in a certain sense now
what we wanted to find is a limit of if
you think of a word like ABC a BBB as a
colored finite order then we wanted to
find a limit of those and you can so if
you have a regular language of finite
words you can create an homogeneous
structure which corresponds somehow to
the limit of all words in that regular
language and then that's useful to to do
some stuff so that's an one example of a
homogeneous structure another nice
example is if you take bit vectors so
you're you you you have and a infinite
base and but each bit each vector is
only allowed to use finitely many okay
so and then that so that's your universe
so these are bit vectors over infinitely
many is so strings of bits of infinite
length which are almost everywhere zero
and your function is a bitwise addition
so addition module two that's a
homogeneous structure and and this is a
nice example because for example if you
use that a modern
structure and you used so that you you
you use Turing machines over that there
is a very natural language that you
might want to consider so your alphabet
is the atoms so these bit vectors and
what your language is or maybe a
function is that the word well it's
called a language you get an input of
letters 10 letters / and unbounded
number of letters are a separator and
the candidate and then a bit vector you
want to know if they're linearly
independent and judge it's a
well-defined finite alphabet in the new
sense and you might ask is it computable
by a Turing machine and in this model
under these definitions and it turns out
that it's not so if you allow non
deterministic turing machine it's ok but
if you restrict to determinism you
cannot do it so independence of vectors
is an example of something that you
cannot do indeterminate it's another
natural example
so there seems to be no need to start in
the society for first of the structures
for example you can start from Tamil
logical spaces and we have many silly
things thanks I'll have to think about
that I mean that's yeah so I guess why
are you perspective here is Jerry the
King structures were the stone spacer
into spaces first order types it's
simple and then you're deriving some
recursion theory consequences about it
like for example this programming
language terminates in finite time so
this seems very similar to like
stability here in model theory where you
know you have some simplicity
assumptions about the type space and
then and then you prove some tameness
results about definable sense so is
there sort of do you think that this
sort of lies in some corresponding
theory like analogous to I'm not sure
there's much of a connection of
stability theory because I guess I mean
I'm very not very knowledgeable of
ability theory but like the bogeyman of
stability theory is the rational numbers
of order that's like there's an unstable
yeah sure but I'm a stability Theory
understood generally so not just stable
necessarily but there's this whole
higher here you know stable nip you know
this is host i'm not sure if there's a
little is interesting i like to think
about it more men don't want to give you
like an answer but i i'm not sure if
these things develop in the same
direction so i think that the properties
which are like the tameness properties
which are done instability like nip for
example so i guess that the example i
gave to dana's to dana's question which
would be the bit vectors this structure
i would guess it doesn't have nits
independence independence the word
appears in box and stage has to be the
case and nevertheless it's very tame
with respect to this year so i'm not
sure if there's a connection with that
particular line but you never knows i
don't want to rule that
okay okay among the first of the two
theorems if the structure of the atoms
and it's elimination of quantifiers what
is the universal so this is so because
you say it's really a big one be fine
yes so so if you're at and are
homogeneous then they have elimination
and you have that and I think that
actually the proof factors through the
property that you just mentioned like
that that's a quick answer might be
incorrect question is this or you could
even collapse to the existential
fragment should also be enough or on for
this theorem so the conclusion says that
you will never have the deterministic
are enough that's never going to happen
but sometimes you can drop to non
deterministic well this is a counter
example so you're never going to go down
to deterministic but you might be able
to go down from alternating to non
deterministic and there what I believe
to be sufficient is that the theory
collapses to the existential fragment
one more I just understand about the
programming language in the example for
its activity we know that if star
actually is ready go MA tree and
inductive define ability collapses
restaurant in a strong way every
inductive definition has finitely many a
finite closer or dinner is that what is
going on yes that's exactly what's going
on yeah okay I think we should wrap up
Las acne go again
coffee break and we'll resume at